[Música]
eu eu tinha pensado em muitas formas de
de começar a falar nesse encontro hoje
mas eu eu sei lá uns dois três dias
antes de vir pra cá recebi um e-mail que
me chamou muita atenção nesse meio dizia
é um pouco algumas orientações que a
gente recebeu pra poder da cnec roupas a
seriam legais de de investir por conta
da luz da câmera e o que a gente podia
fazer também em casa a gente ficasse um
pouco mais nervoso e ansioso e aí numa
uma dessas indicações é dizia assim se
você palestrante será a minha versão não
é ficar nervoso é encontre na platéia um
dois ou três rostos com os quais você
possa conversar ea partir daí você vai
se sentir mais seguro
e aí quando eu vi aquilo eu fiquei
desesperada porque eu pensei pô se essa
foi a única forma que que eu que eu
encontrar com o público de me sentir
segura eu ia ficar muito mal e eu queria
combinar uma coisa com você então apesar
de não parecer eu não vejo nada
eu preparei aqui algumas coisas pra
gente conversar e eu queria saber que
vocês estão comigo
e pra mim é importante ouvir a
respiração de vocês um hum
de vez em quando me faz saber que tá
todo mundo aí também
então para a gente começar junto e essa
forma de começar
tem tudo a ver
com o trabalho que eu faço e com um
pouco e um pouco da proposta que eu vim
trazer queria saber se pode ser assim
é uma coisa que me chamou a atenção
nesse meio que eu recebi também nessa
indicação foi que a priori a gente
considera que não vai ter uma pessoa
cega participando de determinadas coisas
é eu achei muito importante isso
acontecer aqui nessa no ténis e dex
neste momento com essa plataforma porque
só assim a gente pode falar disso aqui
porque se eu não tivesse recebido esse
meio é eu estaria falando de outra coisa
agora e eu acho que o que aconteceu diz
respeito a todos nós porque diz respeito
a uma maneira da gente pensar e essa
maneira da gente pensar é é construída
pelas pessoas com deficiências sem
deficiência
eu acredito muito que que as palavras
elas produzem sentidos que as palavras
vão criando realidades e que elas têm
muita força né ea gente faz muitas
coisas com as palavras e somos feitos
por muitas palavras também e as palavras
com que a gente escolhe nomear o que é o
que a gente é o que a gente sente o que
a gente faz o que a gente percebe
elas são mais do que simples palavras é
existe uma luta pelas palavras pelo
significado das palavras pelo controle
das palavras pela imposição de certas
palavras em prol do silenciamento de
outras palavras é essa luta nessa luta o
que está em jogo é muito mais do que
simples palavras e porque isso me
interessa porque no campo da
acessibilidade é a maneira como a gente
emprega palavra deficiência é decisiva
pra para a política e para a direção do
trabalho que a gente se propõe a
realizar
nesse campo a maneira como a gente
encara a deficiência não me interessa
porque isso vai definir o aspecto
político do trabalho que a gente vai
realizar o que eu quero dizer com isso
né
ao longo dos últimos séculos a história
da deficiência no ocidente ela vem sendo
definida por um saber médico que traduza
deficiência como falta déficit em
capacidade que vai traçando ali uma
história de uma tragédia pessoal que
toma vida das pessoas com deficiência eo
imaginário da vida das pessoas sem
deficiência
isso acontece essa concepção ela está
presente o tempo inteiro ela está
presente aqui agora em está presente no
campo de de realização do meu trabalho
que é o centro cultural e qual é o
problema dessa concepção de deficiência
o problema dessa concepção pautada na
falta no déficit na incapacidade é que
ela conduza a gente para um certo tipo
de intervenção nesse campo com um certo
tipo de atuação é que vai instaurar uma
assimetria
como assim uma simetria né é como eu eu
disse ah as palavras têm força e elas
são construídas
nada é feito e dado a priori então a
deficiência o termo deficiência é
construído da mesma forma que o termo
eficiência é construído e quando eu falo
de assimetria que essa concepção
ocidental de deficiência ela pode fazer
aparecer o que estou dizendo é que
muitas vezes as pessoas sem deficiência
consideradas eficientes intervém numa
determinada prática com as pessoas com
deficiência de modo a restituir uma
falta de modo a fazer aparecer alguma
coisa que ali não tem e o que isso faz
com a nossa
a vida com a vida das pessoas com
deficiência coloca gente numa posição
inferior com relação à posição das
pessoas sem deficiência e é dessa
assimetria que eu estou dizendo e essa
assimetria que essa concepção de
deficiência causa no nosso dia a dia
e existe uma maneira da qual eu lanço
mão no meu trabalho uma metodologia é
para interferir no campo da
acessibilidade que a gente chama de
pesquisar com e que é esse pesquisar com
no meu trabalho pesquisar com ele se
contrapõe a uma metodologia muito comum
no campo da acessibilidade da educação e
que vem se tornando cada vez mais mais
forte que são os manuais é muitas vezes
eu sou convidada para falar sobre
acessibilidade e as pessoas esperam
ouvir de mim o que elas devem ou não
fazer quando elas encontram uma pessoa
com deficiência
é disso que os manuais tratam os manuais
tratam do que é certo e errado de como
proceder de como é uma determinada
experiência vinculado a uma determinada
deficiência
só que os manuais eles são orientados
para uma intervenção que vai numa
direção de fazer para os outros que é
uma orientação extremamente importante
mas ela é muito insuficiente para dar
conta da complexidade que é o trabalho
no campo da acessibilidade estão aí ea
minha proposta aqui hoje é que a gente
possa pensar
ou a gente possa começar a pensar para
além desses manuais de acessibilidade
que eu repito apesar de serem
importantes eles são muito insuficientes
porque eles dizem respeito muitas vezes
adaptações arquitetônicas ou adaptações
informacionais no caso de um centro
cultural por exemplo mas eles não
questionam as maneiras como vêm sendo
propostas quando são paulo
costas experimentações mais estéticas de
uma determinada obra de arte ou de uma
determinada exposição e aí nesse momento
é eu preciso alertar vocês de uma coisa
que é a seguinte é topa' pensar em um
trabalho de acessibilidade que vá para
além dos manuais é se colocar em risco e
que risco é esse é o risco da gente tem
que se transformar os manuais eles em
geral eles têm servido como um
dispositivo de informação uma tentativa
de garantir uma trajetória um encontro
que é incerto que que a gente não tem
como saber a priori como vai ser e que é
é uma trajetória que é feita no encontro
com o outro e não só sobrou para a
pessoa com quem a gente está trabalhando
de fato é que os manuais eles não tratam
de histórias
eles tratam do daquilo que está pronto e
as histórias elas não não estão prontas
as histórias elas estão sempre por vir e
as histórias elas se dão no encontro
as histórias se dão a partir dos
encontros que a gente tem né
e os manuais eles se dão para antecipar
o encontro eles surgem na tentativa de
garantir o sucesso de um determinado
encontro
e é por isso que que eles não lidam com
histórias ou pelo menos os manuais eles
não lidam com histórias em movimento
os guias e os manuais eles estão sempre
diante de histórias cristalizadas
naturalizados histórias que se torna
únicas e assim como as palavras têm
força eu acredito muito que as histórias
também tem força e as histórias fazem de
nós quem nós somos para o bem e para o
mal
uma história ela pode abrir a vida de
alguém por um campo cheio de
possibilidades
do mesmo modo que a gente pode com uma
história destruir a vida de alguém
no caso da experiência da deficiência
como em muitos outros casos também
insistir só nas histórias hegemônicas na
história pautada no déficit na
incapacidade na falta é superficializa
essa experiência é negligenciar muitas
outras histórias que constitui a
experiência da deficiência é criar
estereótipos e como já diria a china
amanda numa conferência feita no ted o
problema do estereótipo não é que ele
está errado não é que ele seja em uma
mentira naquele seria incorreto o
problema do estereótipo é que ele é
incompleto
eles fazem uma história tornassem tornar
uma história única e nesse momento eu
não posso deixar de dizer que essa
concepção com a qual a gente vive
convive diariamente da deficiência ela
tem dois aspectos duais que é hora a
pessoa com deficiência tratado como
coitada como vítima é ea gente está
diante de uma tragédia pessoal ou hora a
vida da pessoa com deficiência tratada
de uma maneira romantizada é o cego que
ver para além de todas as coisas que vê
mais que todo mundo é que vê a alma das
pessoas e é essa dualidade ela não não
diz da profundidade que a experiência da
deficiência
e aí o que a gente pode pensar então
sobre a palavra deficiência né
o compromisso ético do trabalho que que
eu realizo ele está em alcançar as
várias versões do que é a deficiência e
dessa maneira a alcançar as várias
versões da vida dos outros e não é
incomum que a história da deficiência
ela seja trazida priori pelos livros por
filmes é pelas leis pelos manuais que é
o que acontece frequentemente como eu já
disse na área da cultura e da educação
uma proposta é pra mim uma proposta
efetiva de acessibilidade ela se faz
pela via do contato consigo mesmo para
que se possa pra que a gente possa
entrar em contato com o
foi o que eu quero dizer com isso né
primeiro que existe uma aposta no que é
experimental e o experimental ele é um
conceito indicador para um trabalho de
acessibilidade que abre espaço para um
campo cheio de possibilidade para que
nós pessoas com e sem deficiência a
gente possa ouvir e contar mais
histórias novas histórias a respeito
dessa experiência e eu tô no conceito de
experimental como sendo uma ação que
traz novos valores novas leituras e
assumiu experimental num trabalho de
acessibilidade é assumir por exemplo que
uma obra de arte ela não tem sentido em
se de uma curadoria de um curador de uma
exposição ele não produzem se à leitura
por parte de um visitante mas garante
que existe nesse processo de uma
sensibilidade pautada no experimental
que garante que existe e persiste nesse
processo uma positividade alguma coisa
que está esperando para emergir e aí
desse modo retoma a ideia de que esse
trabalho ele pretende tornar mais densa
as nossas vidas e as vidas das pessoas
com deficiência a partir de novas
leituras e de novos referenciais o que
toda essa discussão nessas podem estar
pensando se essa camisa até aí falando
tudo isso palavra história o que tudo
isso tem a ver com a discussão de um
programa de acessibilidade em museus e
centros culturais
primeiro que a gente é responsável pela
escolha metodológica que a gente faz
para realizar o trabalho que a gente
realiza
então como pensar numa metodologia de
trabalho que possibilite o surgimento de
novas histórias a respeito das nossas
vidas das vidas das pessoas com
deficiência e desse modo fazer para
oliver proliferar novas versões a
respeito dessa experiência que fuja ao
fatalismo ou essa romantização dessa
experiência que nos toma desculpa que
nos toma pensar numa nova metodologia de
trabalho ela
implica que a gente vai ter que se
comprometer com que ela vai produzir e
aí pensando nisso eu pergunto né
que efeitos um programa de
acessibilidade pautado em manuais
baseados em informações produzem nas
nossas vidas e que efeitos um programa
de acessibilidade pautado numa dimensão
da criação da invenção e do experimental
produz nas nossas vidas
há uma diferença de produção de vidas e
de mundos envolvido nessas duas
possibilidades
a minha aposta é de que sim
outra coisa que que eu acho muito muito
importante de considerar é que o outro
com deficiência ele não é um sujeito
doce o sujeito qualquer mas antes nós
somos um sujeito é expert no que diz
respeito à experiência das nossas vidas
um sujeito que somos um sujeito que
podemos formular as questões que são
interessantes para um programa de
acessibilidade e que eu quero dizer com
isso mais uma vez que eventualmente a
gente acaba esquecendo que a gente pode
aprender com a gente se prepara pra se
encontrar com outro esquece uma dimensão
de aprender com o outro e isso tem se
tornado cada vez mais distante da nossa
realidade principalmente nas discussões
com acessibilidade e o que eu acho
importante mais uma vez marcar é que
esse cultivo e essa capacidade de reagir
ela implica que a gente possa se
transformar no trabalho que a gente faz
transformar os nossos referenciais e nos
colocar em questão que eu quero dizer
com isso é que eu para trabalhar com
acessibilidade eu tenho que colocar a
minha deficiência em questão que vocês
para se relacionarem com o sistema
precisam se colocar em questão
e aí se faz necessário neste momento
pensar que a acessibilidade ela não é um
um conjunto de ações que têm como meta é
alcançar ou proporcionar um conhecimento
uma informação a priori
mas sim pensar a acessibilidade como a
criação de condições de possibilidade
para a produção de múltiplos sentidos na
experiência com a arte
e aí nesse sentido a inserção de pessoas
com deficiência em museus e centros
culturais
é um dispositivo transformador tanto de
questões políticas de exclusão social
como o analisador para o funcionamento
dessa instituição
do mesmo jeito que o email que recebi
com o qual eu escolhi abrir a minha fala
ele também é um analisador pra como esse
evento se organiza e para quem a gente
espera aqui a gente aposta na
experimentação estética e no que pode
ser partilhado com uma dimensão ética e
política ética e política de se fazer
acessibilidade e dessa maneira produzir
novas possibilidades de vida dentro e
fora do museu e o que é é que eu
considero isso é uma das coisas mais
importantes é pra mim na minha vida na
minha experiência como pessoa com
deficiência é que uma estratégia
inclusiva ela o que ela deve fazer com a
gente é menos uma tentativa da gente se
colocar no lugar do outro que é um lugar
que talvez a gente nunca consiga ocupá e
mais uma tentativa da gente se ocupar do
nosso próprio lugar no encontro com o
outro e com a diferença do outro
eu não posso terminar sem dizer que o
trabalho que eu faço ele está
acompanhado de muitas pessoas é de muita
gente de muitos grupos de estudos nas
pessoas que me formaram e principalmente
da pucca que está aqui hoje que coloca
questões que são fundamentais para o
trabalho de acessibilidade porque a
pucca é um dispositivo que faz falar e
não faz calar e eu acho que é esse
dispositivo é com esse dispositivo que a
gente cria um programa de acessibilidade
obrigada
[Aplausos]